bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv fil 78
édition spéciale du 7-8 jusqu'au 1er
janvier la rédaction revient sur les
événements qui ont marqué 2012 ceux qui
font l'actualité aussi en 2013 cinq
émissions à découvrir pour cinq
thématiques politiques environnement
économie sport et ce soir culture
bonsoir johanna dont deux invités pour
nous accompagner au cours de la
prochaine demi heure avec nos christophe
leray du château de breteuil et à vos
côtés nous reilhac in with chargé du
secteur jeunesse de déclic théâtre voilà
ensemble nous allons donc parler de
l'année 2013 des nouveautés pour le
château de breteuil et déclic avec la
compagnie de trappes déclic théâtre le
château de breteuil 26 minutes
d'éditions spéciales du 7-8 à suivre dès
à présent
on va commencer par l'improvisation
14e édition c'est bien ça du championnat
d'improvisation c'est ça ouais sefiani
chiffres je me suis pas posé la question
mais on doit être à peu près à ça c'est
déjà la 14e édition on va en parler
forcément de cette édition là mais on
peut peut-être déjà dans les grandes
lignes de repréciser en quoi ça consiste
à ta provocation et ben l'improvisation
les mages un procès deux équipes qui se
rencontrent sur les thèmes d'un arbitre
voilà et puis c'est juger par le public
en direct
voilà et puis ça permet de désigner un
vainqueur à ces rencontres de théâtre
c'est entre collèges combien des tables
et la cie qui mitent on a le site mythe
qui se déroule sur sa quentin en
yvelines qu'intermittent c'est quoi ces
championnats inter collèges de match
d'improvisation théâtrale donc
on l'appelle sikimic je sais que ça fait
un cycle un peu un sigle de plus mais
n'entrait s'appelle le cycle mythe et et
donc on a dix collèges de saint quentin
sur mon pti nimani trappe elancourt
élargie avec le collège du mini cave de
la verrière et de maurepas qui accueille
les élèves d'elancourt de plus en plus
d'établissements sont volontaires pour y
participer parce qu'il ya un vrai projet
pédagogique aussi ça m'a énormément de
demande est de plus en plus après nous
sur ce projet là c'est vrai qu'on est un
petit peu dans la contrainte aussi parce
que
voilà on n'est pas au népal en une
compagnie qui si elle a besoin de
s'étendre aujourd'hui voilà doit grandir
dans son ensemble mais mais voilà des
comédiens en fait de déclic qui
interviennent dans les collèges tout au
long de l'année qui prépare les élèves
pendant des halles de lizac te ment des
formations sur 30 heures sur chacun des
collèges qui participent à ce projet là
et
et qui entrecoupés de quatre temps forts
avec une série de phases de match dans
l'enceinte de leur collège qui aura lieu
en janvier d'ailleurs pour les premiers
une série de matches où les collèges
vont se déplacer dans d'autres pour
jouer contre d'autres collèges c'est ce
qu'on appelle le match intercollèges la
rencontre entre trois établissements une
qui vote et 2 qui se rend compte c'est
une grande organisation quand même c'est
un dispositif dispositif qui est
qui effectivement qui aujourd'hui tourne
bien qu'ils aient soutenu par la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin et et tv fils d'ailleurs qui qui
nous accompagne sur ce projet là tous
les ans depuis quelques années notamment
puis plein d'autres et c'est et ouais
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est une
affaire qui qui qui tourne pas mal y
aller salle de spectacles de saint
quentin qui s'investissent aussi dans le
projet cette année le prisme le scarabée
pour nous accueillir en finale et la
merise comme d'habitude sur sur les
matches de qualification christophe
leray vous êtes venu nous parler du
château de breteuil puisque vous êtes en
charge de l'événementiel là bas mais
vous avez aussi une compagnie théâtrale
la troupe du crâne exacte a reçu
occasion sur ce plateau pour en parler
l'improvisation pour vous vous en avez
fait un tout petit peu meilleure plus
classique pour nous c'est plus classique
voilà notre registre mais c'est tout
aussi impressionnant est intéressant
tous les théâtres
me plaisent donc oui la l'improvisation
moi je suis pas spécialement aguerris
mais à creuser peut-être et bientôt la
patinoire prochain justement en parlant
de nouveaux qui entrent dans la
patinoire on avait reçu papy donc le
directeur artistique de déclic théâtre
en plateau qui nous disait que peut-être
omar sy viendrait y aurait peut-être
quelque chose qui serait faire avec lui
alors maintenant on savait plus
aujourd'hui c'est la question alors moi
je ne suis pas au courant à titre
personnel très sincèrement après
effectivement omar sy
jamais jamais rentré dans la patinoire
pour faire vos marcy n'est jamais rentré
dans la patinoire pour faire de l'impro
déjà venu à déclic pour par contre oui
par qui il est il est très proche de la
compagnie par l'esprit comme les autres
comédiens qui qui connaissent notre
compagnie de près et effectivement il je
pense que je pense que c'est un grand
rêve c'est un grand rêve pour tout le
monde de pouvoir rassembler tous ces
comédiens qu'on réussit à déclic qui ont
des parcours fabuleux aujourd'hui est
qui et qui aimeraient pouvoir rassembler
tout ce monde là où il peut tout à tout
le monde on a envie puisqu'en mars on
l'avait rencontré aussi sûreté des fils
lorsqu'il est venu à saint quentin en
yvelines présenter son dernier film et
on lui a parlé de cette éventualité de
rentrer dans la patinoire faire de
l'impro il a dit pourquoi pas il n'y
avait pas pensé mais c'est effectivement
une idée à creuser donc voilà on va
réussir par un de ses fils à
l'entraînement on va
alors prendre la compagnie aussi
d'autres spectacles qui sont joués ya
lysistrata notamment qui avait
interprété à l'année dernière par
mélanie mélanie lemoine et papy c'était
à la ferme du mousseau et à la merise
aussi en mars 2012 et cette année donc
le spectacle va être repris la pièce va
être le genre
oui alors la pièce va être rejoué pour
l'instant on est encore en recherche
d'un lieu sur paris et on essaye de
douala ii de diffuser ce spectacle un
maximum parce qu'on est très fier d'eux
de ce projet là qui est une vraie
réussite déjà artistique pour la
compagnie et c'est un spectacle qui va
être joué la gagne
attendez je regarde pas me tromper mais
le 26 janvier à 20h45 à l'espace albert
camus c'est 6 euros l'entrée reste que
quelques places je le dis là pour ceux
que ça intéresse et pour ceux qui n'ont
pas encore fait leurs cadeaux de noël ou
qu'on des cadeaux en retard après
reposant le nouvel an voilà c'est juste
des conditions du direct je le rappelle
aux des
quoi qu'il en soit voilà si voilà c'est
très intéressant ça traite de l'égalité
hommes femmes
avec ce court avec beaucoup d'humour
c'est une pièce d'aristophane à la base
est encore d'actualité aujourd'hui ça
c'est fou d'aller un petit peu réécrite
pour pour qu'elle parle voilà au public
qu'on essaye d'atteindre aussi et les
voilà et mélanie et pape sy ont fait un
énorme travail là dessus
et on est très fier de ce projet là en
tout cas on espère qu'il va qui va être
qu'il va être vu par un maximum de
personnes donc ça vous allez ouvrir un
petit peu l'année 2013 avec avec lazy
strata ya aussi une autre nouveauté
c'est des ateliers pour adultes sur
magny les hameaux ça c'est quelque chose
qui c'est qui est vraiment s'est ouvert
cette année là en septembre alors oui
c'est ça existe depuis depuis septembre
on est
on a un soutien là dessus de la ville de
manille qui nous commandent ce projet là
et nous voilà ça nous intéresse
effectivement d'avoir des saint
quentinois parce que en plus c'est vrai
que bon c'est un territoire très étendu
que l'on peut pas répondre non plus sur
trappe ou sur nos en vrille les environs
de trappes à toutes les demandes c'est
quelque chose qui est de plus on a
vraiment énormément de demandes et c'est
assez difficile des fois pour nous de de
merde c'est pas l'envié qui nous manque
c'est vraiment la difficulté de
retrouver des créneaux de retrouver des
gens pour faire les ateliers tous a
effectivement eu cette idée d'avoir
monté statut lille assure magny les
hameaux en plus sa rencontre un vrai
succès avec des adultes et des
adolescents et ca mais le indian qui
fait un gros travail sur terrain pour
déclic théâtre je la salue elle et les
autres intervenants et qui s'occupe de
ça et puis s'il ya des gens qui sont
intéressés ya encore des places soit la
dengue ou dans les groupe addoha magny
les hameaux
ado il ya d'eau il reste elle que et
pour les adultes c'est complet je crois
mais l'odeur de l'impro à n'importe quel
âge on peut faire de n'importe donné
c'est n'importe quoi non non non pas de
n'importe quoi non on peut faire on peut
faire de l'impro
il n'y a rien qui peut nous empêcher de
faire dans l'amour c'est quand même pu
dire quand on est adulte sinon c'est un
autre monde retenu peut-être pour
forcément pour les enfants est alors
quand on est enfant et qu'on devient
adulte et qu'on aime pratiquer toute sa
vie on il ya des questions qu'on se pose
pas quand on est adulte quand on
commence quand on est adulte
effectivement il ya un travail un peu
plus un peu il ya un peu plus d'efforts
à faire j'ai envie de dire sur
le côté ou sur son image voilà sur
comment on s'amuse sans
sentir jugé voilà mes mais voilà après
c'est pas quelque chose c'est c'est tout
à fait possible il faut faire de l'impro
qu'on a vu bien au contraire il faut y
aller il faut c'est un peu
juste pour finir et puis sur fait on est
adulte
on rencontre quand on se met à faire des
matches joués à vous savez de quoi je
parle on rencontre des gens qui sont
souvent plus aguerris que nous et qui
nous accompagnent et du coup qui le met
à l'aise et qui nous permettent de jouer
des choses qu'on sur lesquels on se
serait passé moi je pense à issa doumbia
qui était mon premier prof est que
justement m'a donné cette confiance
merci ça mais on continue à parler
d'improvisation avec déclic théâtre on
parlera du château de breteuil également
juste une petite pause avec un retour
sur cette opération pulsations urbaine
c'est en novembre dernier vous l'avez
découvert sur notre antenne wi
l'improvisation qui fait partie des
cultures urbaines c'est une thématique
qui est cher à l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines plus assure ben non
content envahi le territoire saint
quentinois depuis 2012 un exemple avec
secours à magny les hameaux de hip hop
games
d'habitude idriss da silva donne des
cours de hip hop aujourd'hui c'est lui
l'élève il est venu découvrir le concept
des hypothèses on entendu parler mon est
fait pour voir aujourd'hui le musicalité
le style le groove le feeling ça les hip
hop games ont été créés par romuald
brizolier champion du monde de hip hop
en 2009 cette année le concept
s'installe à saint quentin en yvelines
dans le cadre des pulsations urbaine une
thématique chère à l'agglomération à
magny les hameaux johanna faye a proposé
un stage d'initiation au hip hop game ce
concept durant tout un après-midi c'est
s'amuser et
ne surtout pas se juger et juste écouter
et pas avoir peur d'être acceptée si on
est dedans c'est quoi générale il ya
quatre groupes ils sont composés de
quatre personnes et en fait ces quatre
personnes elle veut faire tour à tour
des égouts des oeufs les équipes
s'affrontent lors d'un show en plusieurs
épreuves improvisé avec l'autre joué
autour d'un objet lippok games recherche
une dimension théâtrale dans la danse
sur trois musiques avoir trois gestuelle
différentes trois ans tension dû prendre
trois personnages différents et ensuite
quand la musique switch pouvoir suit ce
personnage le hip hop game ce concept
une performance à mi chemin entre battle
les créations
pas moi
dernière date d'initiation samedi 10
novembre à trappes avant le show de hip
hop game ce concept à guyancourt le
samedi 17 novembre
les pulsations urbaines qui se
poursuivra saint-quentin-en-yvelines
jusqu'en juin 2013 et déclic théâtre
avait participé oui je sais pas
jonah vous êtes mir hossein
moussavi plateau découverte jaoui
nationale merci at il ajouté précisant
c'est pas bien c'est de changer de place
et c'est vrai que pour les gentils ce
qui réduit le début de l'émission on
avait arrêté le 16 juillet en tout cas
c'est le mardi 9 avril voilà ce sera un
plateau découverte dirigée par pape sy
directeur artistique de déclic théâtre
voilà puis aussi deux trophées culture
et diversité pour déclic qui a été lancé
il ya deux ans avec jamel debbouze issus
de la compagnie et la fondation culture
et diversité
alors en quoi ces différentes du
championnat intercollèges justement ce
trophée est bien même période en fin
d'année c'est pareil ça c'est un projet
qui qui est
qui suit le championnat intercollèges
simplement
simplement ça sert toujours à des
collégiens simplement c'est un projet
national qui est soutenu par la colle à
la fondation culture et diversité et
donc on intervient au même titre qu elle
intervient sur des villes
saint-quentinoise à bordeaux à rochefort
à lille et le collège qui représente
effectivement la ville de trappes sont
le collège de gary neal collège courbet
est ce que tout ça est reconduit cette
année en 2013 est reconduit en 2013
voilà avec ces quatre villes là parce
que peut-être on pense un jour élargir à
d'autres vivre ça marche pas mal c'est
alors on pense forcément à élargir
on en a une énorme envie simplement
voilà le on en est encore une on est
encore en train d'envisager les choses
on imagine différentes formules parce
que parce que voilà ça ça risque de nous
demander encore effectivement une
capacité d'intervention et là je
minimise pas le fait qu'on ne puisse pas
faire les choses je veux parce que tout
est alors chez un petit peu sûr de la
retenue mais mais c'est vrai que voilà
il ya ça pose à sa pause ça pose des
questions et on se l'est posée on va
trouver les réponses et puis si on peut
le développer on développera avec grand
bonheur maintenant mais sûrement voilà
on peut le dire comme ça l'année 2013
aussi une grande année parce que déclic
fait c'est j'entends tout à fait
simple c'est à dire qu on a tellement
été filmée par tv fils que je vais vous
demander on a un train de préparer une
petite série de vidéos voilà qui dure
dix secondes où on nous demande où on
demande aux gens de nous c'est les de
nous souhaiter un joyeux anniversaire
je demande à
ma fille m'a dit voilà je t'en prie de
nous dire un petit jeu d'anniversaire à
petit la balle alors vous risquez alors
donc le du tout dans le cadre c'est pas
qu'il a disparu de l'écran
donc joyeux anniversaire et anniversaire
abeilles qui fête ses 20 ans fait les
tva belge comme on dit en espagnol on le
fait en france et aussi félicitations
bien sûr
voilà pour ces petits messages en direct
vous pouvez suivre ce sera diffusée ou
comment vous allez vous organiser pour
les ventes et on va faire pour pardon je
n'avais pas ma soeur on est à dire c'est
sympa on va le on va le diffuser
on va diffuser tout au long de l'année
sur différents supports voilà sa pivot
nous apporterait le gâteau la prochaine
fois que vous venez en plateau non avec
les bougies oui ah oui grand bonheur
effectivement on viendra fêter on peut
fêter les 20 ans sur le plateau ici
allègrement profitera pour fêter les 20
ans de tv fils aussi parce que c'était
l'année 2012 l'année des 20 ans
lancement en tout cas de 2 la chaîne
c'est un plateau avec nous on va parler
du château de breteuil un petit détour
par la russie auparavant bien loin de
saint quentin en yvelines oui on va
voyager nous à l'orthodoxie célébré en
janvier l'année dernière nous avions
fêté ce noël original avec des enfants
franco-russes d'une association de
versailles
c'est dans la nuit du 6 au 7 janvier que
le père noël russe dépose les cadeaux au
pied du sapin les enfants l'appellent
jet malo ce qui signifie grand père du
froid il ne vient jamais seul puisqu'il
est toujours accompagné de sa petite
fille snegourotchka depuis plusieurs
années tous deux font escale à
versailles pour offrir des cadeaux aux
enfants de l'association russophone
d'abord pour nos enfants qui sont
français qui sont bilingues qui veulent
apprendre les cultures de l'anc russe et
après cette association le renier leurs
parents et plus maintenant les gens qui
ont peu trop loin de là aussi de la
langue russe mais quand même ils veulent
apprendre la langue de culture celle
intéresse l'association née en 2006
propose des cours de langue pour adultes
mais aussi des ateliers pour enfants les
plus jeunes apprennent ainsi la pratique
du russe écrit et parlé
nous avons majorité des familles si on
peut dire mix franco russe où il n'y a
pas d'exemple mamans et aux rousses et
père français après on a des familles
qui sont français mais dans leur
histoire peut être grand mère grand père
l'était quelques elle avait quelques
liens avec la russie
excusez moi j'ai grandi bilingue déjà
maintenant et russes et moi mon père est
français dont que j'ai reçu déjà
bilingues de nationalités et de cultures
et je le transmets mes enfants pour
qu'elle parle russe parce que j'ai envie
que ma fille par la langue dont mes
parents me parlait et donc pour moi
c'est très important
outre les cours de langues l'association
organise des ateliers d'artisanat russe
ouvert à tous et si vous souhaitez
encore faire la fête vous pouvez
célébrer le vieux nouvel an russe qui a
eu lieu le vendredi 13 janvier
le château de breteuil à présent qu'il
va nous intéresser pour cette édition
spéciale du 7-8 dédié à la culture nous
sommes toujours en période de fêtes de
fin d'année et pendant cette période là
le château de breteuil propose beaucoup
d'activités à quoi ressemble le château
pendant cette période et bien tout
d'abord le château et aux couleurs de
noël éclairées et décorées et puis vous
avez beaucoup d'animations des ateliers
pour les enfants la conteuse qui raconte
les histoires de perrault des contes de
noël des contes d'hiver donc c'est très
familial c'est un moment convivial et
est très sympathique vraiment il ya des
contes de noël et pillé une nouveauté
qui arrivé l'année dernière en avril
2012 c'est un conte autour de paix de
pierrot oui j'allais dire perreault
alors nous allons cette scène de contes
de perrault à breteuil et il y à une
scène qui sort un petit peu du lot
effectivement c'est un conte de michel
tournier qui a été mis en scène dans le
four à pain du domaine l'histoire qui
mise en scène c'est celle de pierrot les
secrets de la nuit 1 michel tournier et
en choisit lien donc il habite à choisel
le petit village qui est autour du
château et il a écrit la plupart de ces
histoires on se promenant dans les
jardins du château de breteuil donc
c'est un clin d'oeil qu'on lui a fait
puisque c'est un ami un ami du château
est en quelque sorte breteuil c'est son
grand jardin tu peux te sympa il ya une
discipline comme ça dans l'impro fera
une catégorie on explique à la manière
des comptes ah oui quand les pierrots de
catégorie il ya une catégorie comté où
il ya eu un joueur qui se détache et qui
va raconter en fait l'histoire qui va
être images et par parent c'est par ses
partenaires de jeu et il ya à la manière
du compte effectivement ou là on
interprète une histoire où on bah voilà
sans s'inspirer de ce décret tel ou
d'autre chose effectivement et puis ça
m'intéresse à tour de bretagne une
région qui est magnifique c'est un
endroit ouais le château de breteuil
c'est très sympa de l'impro château de
breteuil et ben écoutez à 20 jours est
grand bonheur mais pourquoi pas donc
vous connaissez bien breteuil les
jardins vont être un peu mis en valeur
pendant cette année 2013 avec l'arrivée
de l'art contemporain exactement ces
grands dans votez pour nous c'est un
artiste qui s'appelle pierre marie
lejeune qui vit actuellement normandie
et qui travaille et qui va réaliser
plusieurs sculptures spécialement pour
pour breteuil l'idée en fait c'est de
donner un relief un peu étonnant de
créer la surprise dans ses jardins avec
des sculptures à base d'acier de miroirs
et de cristal dans lesquelles les
les jardins vont pouvoir se refléter il
va y avoir des jeux de transparence
l'idée c'est que la sculpture s'intègre
bien à son environnement et qu'elle
permette de le mettre en relief
différemment j'ai vu quelques semaines
cette politique c'est assez joli parce
qu'effectivement ça se font plutôt dans
la nature et vous avez été influencé par
versailles et son art contemporain qui
fait autant parler alors le marquer de
breteuil et au conseil d'administration
du château de versailles donc il n'est
pas étranger à l'arrivée de l'art
contemporain à versailles mais là c'est
plutôt une histoire de coups de coeur de
rencontrer et voilà il ya quelque chose
d'un peu instinctif qui s'est fait
l'artiste nous a séduit alors on s'est
dit mais pourquoi pas essayons et vu
qu'il ya un vrai concept si derrière il
ya un message c'est voilà c'est
intéressant aussi de
de provoquer l'ouverture le dialogue la
surprise et puis peut-être que ça ne
fera pas l'unanimité mais après tout
c'est bien de ne pas être uniforme et
tiède et voilà donc de provoquer le
questionnement alors tous les dimanches
château de breteuil en plus de la visite
il ya des spectacles d'organiser des
pièces de théâtre peut-être bientôt de
l'impro la sai on a lancé une idée des
spectacles des scream aussi des ateliers
macarons vous me disiez alors tous que
c'est gratuit comment ça se passe les
gens se baladent et puis après hop ils
profitent des spectacles alors en fait à
breteuil vous avez deux formules de
visites vous pouvez ou visiter les
jardins les scènes de compte et les
anciennes cuisines du château librement
donc de manière non guidés ça c'est une
première forme de visite où vous pouvez
donc visiter les jardins etc et rajouter
une visite guidée du château dans tous
les cas lorsque vous venez les dimanches
du printemps ou de l'automne il y à une
animation qui est offerte aux visiteurs
à l'ensemble des visiteurs et ça en
général c'est l'après midi et vous avez
donc ou de l'escrim ou du théâtre où les
grenadiers napoli enfin il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de choses y en a vraiment pour
tous les goûts mais ça c'est vraiment
une politique du marquis de breteuil
c'est d'offrir ce spectacle en quelque
sorte les remercier aussi de faire vivre
le château comme il le disait si bien
marquer de breteuil les visiteurs sont
les mécènes de breteuil c'est eux qui
font vivre ce domaine privé et malgré la
crise se porte toujours aussi bien la
fréquentation
le château arrive à très bien équilibrée
en termes de budget et de dépenses et de
recettes et ça c'est assez rare et et on
arrive à stabiliser de notre nombre de
visiteurs et on espère toujours avec de
nouvelles activités de nouvelles
animations dynamiser mais c'est très
important et avoir fait redécouvrir
breteuil au plus grand nombre alors
parlons de nouveautés une surprise pour
le public lors des journées du
patrimoine en septembre c'est un nouveau
personnage de cire qui vient jusqu'à
breteuil nous avons c'est ce qui fait un
peu la particularité du château nous
avons une trentaine de mannequins de
cire réalisée par le musée grévin dans
les salons du château qui met en scène à
la fois les ancêtres de la famille et de
grandes figures de l'histoire de france
donc le parcours est vraiment très
vivant c'est aussi un parcours qui est
très théâtral et et l'a donc nous avons
une grande une grande femme dans la
famille qui s'appelle gabriel et milite
breteuil la marquise du châtelet
première femme de science de l'histoire
une femme des lumières on va dire pour
simplifier les choses égérie de voltaire
et voilà nous avons ces appartements et
beaucoup de visiteurs nous disent mais
il n'ya pas gabriel et midi elle manque
et on en parle beaucoup et c'est
vraiment un destin elle est morte à 43
ans et pourtant voilà ce serait une des
rares femmes qui fera partie maintenant
oui puisqu'on à marie-antoinette mais on
avait très peu de femmes et c'est bien
un petit peu d'apporter cette
sensibilité en plus au château je pense
que vraiment c'est ce sera une valeur
ajoutée vraiment dans la visite et lors
de cette journée aussi un grand bal sera
organisé par l'association carnet de bal
comme comme tous les ans depuis vingt
ans tous les ans trouve un thème
différent là donc nous sommes en 2000
nous allons être en 2013 et
nous allons célébrer le centenaire de la
visite de george cinq rois d'angleterre
à breteuil donc qui est passé en 1913 et
la famille de breteuil a des liens très
forts avec la couronne d'angleterre
édouard 8 a séjourné à breteil pendant
un an pour y apprendre le français nous
avons des archives exceptionnelles avec
des correspondances entre la famille de
breteuil et là la famille royale et
voilà donc c'est une façon aussi de
d'honorer cette amitié d'un château à un
autre on va partir pour château fort à
présent château fait dans la culture et
oui puisque c'est johanna qui écrit mes
textes
alors la neuvième saison de l'émission
star academy cette émission de
téléréalité a débuté c'était le 6
décembre dernier et nous avions
rencontré les présentateurs d'nrj12 à
cette occasion
tonya kinzinger alias jessica dans la
série sous le soleil a rejoint la chaîne
nrj 12 pour présenter la nouvelle saison
de la star academy avec matthieu
delormeau ils présenteront chaque jeudi
en direct le prince où les élèves seront
jugés aux côtés de stars en france est
rare d'avoir un chanteur qui s'élançait
ou un acteur qui sait danser et chanter
aux etats unis c'est déjà dans la
culture d'avoir cette polyvalence mais
ça vient petit à petit en france j'y
suis ravi ça permet aussi parfois de se
séparer ou verrez dans le plateau qu'on
sera pas forcément toujours en formule 1
qui peut faire un lancement et pas
l'autre ça permet d'avoir effectivement
toutes les interviews américaine ce sera
avec des artistes internationaux ce sera
pour tonia la partie de plus de
française pour moi les élèves
intégreront la star academy pour la
neuvième saison de l'émission jeudi soir
les académiciens seront révélés au
public lors du premier prime ils
découvriront alors le château de la
jeunesse situé à châteaufort
des plateaux de la semaine dernière là
bas moi je la trouve très belle
elle est entièrement refaite
très très moderne tout dans un look
musique jeunes un peu tu n'es on va dire
moi compris ce chaton il obtenait et non
elle est très très belle je pense qu'à
l'écran serait jetée même si certains
couleur je n'aurais pas choisi le
scénario je suis allé repérer les lieux
forcément je me suis bon à ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir aller courir dans wow quel
endroit s'il pleut parce qu'on est un
abri pour travailler il ya des couleurs
vives savoir à l'entrée d'andré diot
ilian couleurs qui enfle réveil ça
motive ouais ça motive ça motive ce que
c'est une couleur très
leur sang
après c'est la nature donc nous sommes
dehors donc c'est l'hiver ouais la neige
est tous avec toi juste couvrir c'est
tout vous aurez sûrement reconnu pascal
l'ancien grand frère de tf1 reconverti
en coach sportif et mental mais
officiant toujours dans la télé réalité
pas le but c'est qu'ils puissent tous
des pastous et tout parce qu'il ya aussi
des filles que tout le monde puisse
dépasser ses propres limites donc ça
c'est plus intéressant donc je vais
tester très rapidement la mine de chacun
et puis le but c'est qu'ils puissent y
aller le plus loin possible aussi bien
dans le sport que dans la tête parce que
ça c'est important il faut qu'ils
avaient un mental très très fort et pour
que ce rendez vous le jeudi 6 décembre
sur nrj 12 pour enfin découvrir le
nouvel intérieur du château de lageneste
à châteaufort qui sont conseil sujet qui
a beaucoup fait parler oui à la renault
anakin votre votre point de vue sur la
star academy moi je découvre la star
academy dans les yvelines s'est
peut-être pas au fait de l'actualité
culturelle si de l'actualité culturelle
valadine si c'est justement à ce niveau
que
l'état ferait vous le disais que ça a
perturbé la circulation
voilà qui a été qui a eu quelques petits
soucis à proximité de ce lieu mais pour
revenir à la star academy moi je trouve
que l'idée de concours le gêne un petit
peu voilà donc c'est pas quelque chose
auquel j'adhère particulière on aurait
dû organiser un débat pour cette édition
spéciale autour de la scène locale est
peut-être en 2013 merci à nos deux
invités d'être venu ce soir merci
également johanna prochaine édition du 7
8 en direct ce sera le 2 janvier dès 18
heures nos éditions spéciales qui se
poursuivent jusqu'au 1er janvier elles
sont toutes à retrouver sur notre site
internet excellente fin de soirée sur tv
fier